Me llamo Nanfu.
En chino, "nan" significa "hombre".
Y "fu" significa "pilar".
Mi familia había deseado un niño,
que al crecer se convirtiera en el pilar de la familia.
Y al nacer yo,
me llamaron Nanfu igual.
(Risas)
Nací en 1985,
seis años antes de que China introdujera su política del hijo único.
Justo después de que nací,
los funcionarios le ordenaron a mi madre que se esterilizara.
Mi abuelo enfrentó a los funcionarios,
porque quería un nieto que perpetuara el apellido de la familia.
Al final, se permitió a mis padres tener un segundo hijo,
pero debieron esperar cinco años y pagar una multa elevada.
Durante nuestra infancia,
mi hermano y yo estábamos rodeados de niños de familias con un solo hijo.
Recuerdo sentir vergüenza
por tener un hermano menor.
Sentí que nuestra familia había hecho algo malo al tener dos hijos.
En ese momento,
no me pregunté cuál era la raíz de esta vergüenza y esta culpa.
Hace un año y medio, tuve mi primer hijo.
Fue lo mejor que me ha pasado en la vida.
Convertirme en madre
me dio una nueva perspectiva de mi propia infancia,
y revivió recuerdos de mi juventud en China.
Durante las últimas tres décadas,
todos en mi familia debieron solicitar permiso del gobierno para tener un hijo.
Y me pregunté:
¿cómo era la vida para la gente sometida a la política del hijo único?
Entonces decidí hacer un documental sobre esto.
Una de las personas que entrevisté
fue la partera que se encargó de todos los partos de mi aldea,
incluso del parto en que nací yo.
Tenía 84 años cuando la entrevisté.
Le pregunté:
"¿Recuerda cuántos partos asistió en toda su carrera?".
No tenía un número exacto.
Me dijo que había practicado
60 000 abortos forzados y esterilizaciones.
A veces, me explicó,
un feto sobrevivía al aborto,
y ella mataba al bebé después del parto.
Recordó cómo le temblaban las manos
al realizar este trabajo.
Su historia me impactó.
Cuando empecé a hacer la película,
esperaba que fuera una historia sencilla de responsables y víctimas,
de gente que ejecutó la política
y de la gente que sufre sus consecuencias.
Pero no fue eso lo que encontré.
Mientras acababa mi entrevista con la partera,
noté un área de su casa
que estaba decorada con elaboradas banderas caseras.
Cada bandera tiene la foto de un bebé.
Eran regalos de las familias
cuyos problemas de infertilidad ella había ayudado a tratar.
Me contó que estaba harta de practicar abortos y esterilizaciones,
y que ahora su trabajo se centraba en ayudar a que las familias tuvieran hijos.
Me contó que se sentía llena de culpa
por haber ejecutado la política del hijo único,
y esperaba que el ayudar a las familias a tener hijos
pudiera compensar lo que hizo en el pasado.
Quedó claro que ella era víctima de la política también.
Todos le decían
que su trabajo era esencial y necesario para que China sobreviviera.
E hizo lo que consideró apropiado para su país.
Sé lo fuerte que era ese mensaje.
Al crecer, podía verlo en todas partes.
Se imprimía en cajas de cerillas,
en naipes, en libros, pósteres.
La propaganda que elogiaba la política se encontraba en todas partes.
[Todo aquel que se niegue a esterilizarse será detenido.]
Había amenazas generalizadas también.
El mensaje se filtró en nuestras mentes,
tanto así que crecí sintiéndome avergonzada por tener un hermano menor.
En cada persona que filmé,
pude ver cómo su mente y corazón
habían sido influenciados por la propaganda,
y cómo su disposición a sacrificarse por un bien mayor
había sido distorsionada en algo muy oscuro y trágico.
China no es el único lugar donde ocurre esto.
No existe ningún país del mundo que esté libre de propaganda.
En las sociedades que supuestamente son más abiertas y libres que China,
puede ser aún más difícil detectar la propaganda.
Se esconde a simple vista en forma de reportajes, comerciales de televisión,
campañas políticas y ahora en las redes sociales.
Está diseñada para cambiar la opinión de la gente sin que lo noten.
Toda sociedad es vulnerable a tomar la propaganda como verdad,
y no es posible que una sociedad sea verdaderamente libre
si la propaganda reemplaza la verdad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)